e qui guarda mamma mia che è brutto ma
che cosa sta facendo anche il calcio
colato
e sono proprio quella parte bene
per mano di solito stories guardate
questo personaggio inquietante oggi
nuovissime che insomma dobbiamo scappare
da questo personaggio che si chiama
si chiama boffo lo vedete mano credo che
questi proposti a un po paurosa ma noi
piace la narnese me la cosa può
succedere quando di predisporne richiamo
dove tutti i mondiali gli azzurri c'era
anche quella quella con l'animaletto ii
e iii come si chiamerà quell'animaletto
che stava lì affianco a bob
credo che sia un personaggio
perché esistono dell'ata
jazz lab uno e bino vedi a
febbraio
sembra il plancton l'amico di uomo
visivo questa è una sorta di spongebob
pauroso seguano light exposed umano
pauroso volo topo e cosa hanno infatti
dice ha creduto ho bisogno di aiuto per
ottenere la formula segreta di crabs è
che sarebbe il panino che mangiava spot
per sky
sport
ragionare
e
forse non bisogna saltare sulle rocce ma
se queste rivali ma li muli bauli
barigelli bariti la bauli
che bello l'amore di felice o no attimo
perché stiamo proprio nel ristorante di
spongebob prefetto un po più strano ai
qui guarda mamma mia che brutta
ma che cosa sto facendo anche il
cacciucco lato ma che io la fai hanno
fatto muovere nino preso sposo che
l'hanno trasformato in essere umano per
ottenendo la forma quadrata sono pesanti
sono l'olio delle patatine fritte ma
cosa hai fatto ti ha sprigionato saltare
vabbè io mi sto mangiato le patatine nel
frattempo che arriva a liberarsi di
estrarre si scappa allora devi saltare
su quelle più scure quindi va bene
troppo tesi pensavo il contrario brava
allora vediamo capisce da vito lo re
ovvero cosa queste bolle per arrivare
dall'altra parte
ma forse ho capito
rimaniamo solo su una bolla tanto ci
porta sopra
pronto dobbiamo salire sopra no dobbiamo
fare un'altra parte
io non ce l'ho fatta dai soldi delle
bollette tra i quali ci riprovo
allontaniamo sempre possibile da quello
scorso bob super inquietante però non so
mi ero stanotte ci sono quasi dai e poi
con un altro
uomo guarda le fette di pomodoro e ha
detto non farebbe che estrarre dal cibo
però cade di strage ma stiamo soltanto
sul cibo volante
che non se ne fa rumore
è un coltello che se non dico altri che
vogliono rubato ingredienti o che sia
fettine guarda dall'alto così è più
facile
io sono riuscito a fare anche io stessa
ruby fanno vedere vitale spasso
affettiva
così
salvo per un pelo so cosa fare cioè non
si è stretta su questi fatti per
arrivare a quella porta la giulio
rimasta un po amo fisico e tempo o non
si arrivò dirà ma c'è tempo in cui
pornografica lo sono fatto
antigravitazionali ma ci sono anche le
porte
poi io sono arrivato qui ma non so dove
stiamo andando dentro il frigo e c'era
una porta nera vediamo noi siamo dentro
figo sì c'è un forziere apre questo
forse ma guarda in bandiera potrebbe
essere il codice per la cassaforte il
codice parlare perché ci sono delle mani
qua
è tutto molto strano in questo gioco
vediamo spesso ho trovato una chiave è
chiaro
bravo una chiave dentro questo cassetto
per sé ora posso usarla come papa ei
pieno 6 a 3 forse non era la chiave
giusta
è la chiave per qua perché per il
forziere no perché sto coso che cosa
questo questo tombo ok ma il dottor mula
e amiamo ancora portano la formula
segreta
siamo nella cassaforte nella terza parte
ma perché questi soldi si muovono per
farci passare
di qua
dal prezzo prima di stessimo wow molto
divertente che fuma o che frigo ma
stiamo andando velocissimi tra l'altro
non lo stop e 2 maggio davanti a me è
molto più veloce questo giocatore
che bello se l'abbiamo fatta
passare siamo usciti fuori da chiti sono
fuori dalle scene su perfetto ma mi ha
preso come ti ha presi sono intanto
dalla parte sbagliata mi ha preso bob
rotto
allora proprio può vedere qui quindi lui
ci segue e quindi molto quadrato
a cui si va ad imitarlo
allora corri
rossi ci provoca asma ma non fermarti
non girati anche non bisogna quindi era
quello il trucco basta no non bisogna
girare non ti devi girare non devi
guardarlo altrimenti ti prende
penso che evitino la supervelocità
funziona alla grande
perchè mi ha preso la mano preso questo
tavolo
riproviamo e io sto andando alla grande
è riuscito a portare se si sono
tantissimo ma non so dove andare adesso
ho finito ho finito la supervelocità io
adesso
o no non so dove andare per quanto devo
continuare a scappare ma comunque caputo
dai riesco a vederti cp quasi salta di
salta risalta di aiuto
ai caporali e la guarda io sono qui se
te
pensiamo qua dentro questa è la casa di
dio è una sera c'è un pulsante per
aprire la porta mai a trovare assicurati
di evitare gary hanno allora non è la
sostanza che era la macchina non mi
ricordo pesiamo io esplorare per caserta
si bravo andiamo di qua attento cosa ci
sono marietta la quale un amore
ok riproviamoci dai possiamo farcela
versato camminano comunque allora queste
trappole bisogna attraversarlo e molto
piano
con calma
ok ci vuole un sacco di mostri l'altro
grazie a un pulsante sei riuscito a
passare
quasi
tempo è stata salta salta ma
ho premuto il pulsante forse ora
riusciamo a prendere la ricetta segreta
ma lo devo premere anch'io mica vero
sì certo comportamento non porti sbrozzi
al mare quando ritorni a perché bisogna
anche ritornare è certo ottimo perché mi
sono mai tornato basta perché trovate
schiappa e questo gioco ma a water solo
porta guarda un cappello aperto vita è
riuscito e allora viviamo
non mi dire
facciamo sappiamo ok ho premuto il
pulsante poi dovete è andato nella porta
in quella porta di ok
partiamo sappiamo sappiamo
allora c'è scritto fai piano non
svegliare ieri penso che la formula sia
nel guscio vai a controllare
ieri e in lumacone ha nascosto la
formula nel guscio tele noi facciamo
utile
non mi dire che ti amo per
mangiare ma dobbiamo attraversare tutta
la roma cavo o no ma la roma ha chiuso
le porte di milano certo ci sarà
sicuramente prima parte di una donna che
la partita non banca sara
ma grande mangiano sempre cose strane
perché è una lumaca dove mangiare una
lattina intera un gioco o quindi bisogno
di lorenzo questa colossale dove bisogna
andare qui segnali evitare tutti questa
consiglio ma perché una lattina intera
anche allora attento
una corda americani
eccomi non riesco a capire ma quando
resto a passare forse ma no bisogna
saltare a bisogna evitare negative 19
contrario e lattine
ok riproviamoci
mai mi sarei aspettata che m skype room
di spongebob ora sarebbe stata così
difficile è mai riuscito a passare tu
puoi farcela anche tutti si sono qui
sono qui
sfracellato sei trovato la ricetta o
loprete questa scrivi qualcosa ma non
riesco a prenderla ma sei sicura che sia
quella la forza non è questa
vediamo qua c'è il cuore della luna ma
soprattutto perché è una domanda
dovrebbe custodire la ricetta dentro il
suo guscio perché nessuno ma troverà mai
penso
così passo di aiuto se non fatta davvero
il cuore grande festa lumaca
aiuto dove sei sono qui perché qui su
questa su questi uffici di che sto
cercando di salire dai tra poco ti
aspetta altro cibo davvero team ha
masticato dall'arma meno chiuso che
fantastica allora
c'era tra parte prevede
no no no no no io visto che torno
indietro allora
allora io sono in un posto che tipo lo
stomaco
sembra ci siano
[Musica]
insomma proprio quella parte
tutto la formula è mia
ci siamo resi così vediamo se c'è il
peggio qui dà voce parte
dei capelli
l'attrice scrittori nuovi cappello
tabellata si fa adesso
dipingete stesso dice mai detto per me
perché perché dovrei sono queste porte
qui con
con degli uomini altro pazzo ok cambiato
la faccia vedevo questa crisi o no chi
sono io adesso
non si credo stiamo riesce a prendere
l'abbiamo preso già il vecchio mi sono
vediamo se troviamo qualcos'altro si
pensi sono andato ho messo questa cosa
in testa possiamo volare pure la crew
marito messa dei componenti del computer
sulla mia testa ok dove sei
volando fuori dalle che pronto per
vedere come sta
voglio farti vedere come mi sono
scocciato
ma io non tornerò più normale
mi sono vestito riflessioni computer
sulla testa la scheda madre alla ram
e una scheda grafica la rama della cp
lucio anche affermare ruby va non lo so
intendo per quale motivo esistono questi
capelli e perché è una volta i capelli
ho provato a
quattro che si pubblicare per vedere i
nostri altri video le case su quello che
preferite
migliore ciao